rain snow hail all things we used to
sing fall from the sky on any given day
we don't think twice when it starts to
rain but over the course of history
there have been some truly weird things
to fall on their unsuspecting victims
take for example the strange account of
the town of Lodge Amon in Australia in
2004 the locals of this remote town
reported hundreds and hundreds of small
white fish falling from the sky still
alive as if a freak fish storm isn't
weird enough Lodge Amon who sits on the
edge of the Tanami desert hundreds of
kilometers from Lake Argyle and Lake
Elliott the closest bodies of water most
meteorologists speculate that the
incident was probably caused by a
tornado that would have plucked the fish
from the water launched them into the
weather system where they would have
been essentially frozen and eventually
deposited as fishy hailstones over the
tiny Outback town 2004 wasn't the first
or last time perch fell from the sky and
Lajamanu either in 1980 and twice in
2010 locals were greeted by a light
dusting of seafood on the subject of
food let's travel back in time to March
3rd 1876 it was a clear spring day in
Olympia Springs Kentucky and a certain
mrs. Crouch was making soap outside her
house when she noticed that it had
started to snow not actual snow mind you
but large flakes of what looked like
beef the following day an inspector came
to verify the story and sure enough he
noted the presence of meat flakes
covering the area he said that most of
the flakes were roughly 5 centimetres
square though at least some were twice
that size two unidentified men turned up
and apparently with complete disregard
for their health decided to taste the
meat they declared that it tasted like
either venison or mutton various
explanations were proposed over the
following months some scientists
claiming the flakes were bacteria others
claiming that it was lung tissue of
either human infant or horse until it
was finally confirmed that the
mysterious fleshy precipitation was
indeed meat of some sort in all seven
specimens were examined by scientists
two were confirmed to be lung tissue
three to be muscle tissue and two to be
cartilage but where did they come from
and why did they fall from the sky one
dr. LD Caston bine proposed the most
likely explanation for the phenomenon
were likely ever going to get the meat
he said was the product of a
synchronized barrage of projectile
vulture vomit the two species of vulture
found in Kentucky the black vulture in
the turkey vulture are Bo
known to projectile vomit their stomach
contents as a defense mechanism or to
make themselves light enough for
sustained flight regardless of where the
meat came from I personally would not
have tasted it moving back to more
recent events let's look at the creepy
crawly account of Christian Annette o
gown and his friends who are hiking in
Argentina over their Easter vacation on
April 6 2007 Christian and his friends
were hiking the San Bernardo Mountain
two hours into their Trek they came upon
an area where the ground was completely
blanketed in spiders each about four
inches across unlike your humble
narrator would have done the hikers
continued on their way finding more and
more spiders as they went at one point
they looked up and saw the nightmarish
sight of dozens of spiders falling from
the sky luckily or unluckily Christian
remembered he had a camera with him he
caught a picture of the tiny skydivers
in flight and a close-up of one
beginning to spin its web christian said
the event seemed like something out of a
science-fiction movie versus real life
while spiders can glide without a
parachute just fine larger creatures
tend to have more difficulty with the
whole landing safely thing London
September of 2012 residents of the
Mortlake neighborhood came across a
grisly scene outside a traditional
Chinese medicine shop the mangled body
of an unidentified man the police began
their investigation suspecting foul play
and deduced from the remains that the
victim was approximately five feet four
inches tall and between twenty and
thirty years old they also discovered
that he wasn't murdered at all unless
you can blame gravity his injuries were
sustained from a very long fall
specifically from a passenger jet
authorities suspect that this brilliant
individual decided to stow away on a
plane headed for Heathrow Airport then
probably realized his mistake when the
landing gear was deployed and he fell to
his untimely demise not to worry the
civil aviation authority states that he
probably died long before you at the
ground he was likely crushed when the
landing gear retracted after takeoff or
he may have frozen in the minus 40
degree Celsius compartment much better
than death by inertia right speaking of
the strange relationship between larger
creatures and gravity quite possibly the
strangest thing to fall from the sky was
a cow yep you heard that right
in 1997 some Japanese fishermen were
minding their own business when roughly
1,200 pounds of uncooked hamburger
streak from the sky like a meaty meteor
and left a cow a pole in their boat the
fishermen were eventually rescued after
clinging to the wreckage for several
hours and then promptly put in jail for
claiming their vessel
been sunk by a kamikaze cow the poor
confused fisherman remained in prison
for several weeks until Japanese
authorities got a highly unusual call
from Russian Air Force officials what
really happened was that the crew of a
Russian cargo plane had stolen a cow
that wandered too close to their
Siberian airfield and packed it away in
their plane for the flight home thinking
it would be a good supply of beef
unfortunately the cow started to panic
and caused chaos in the cargo hold
affecting the planes stability this made
the crew exactly nervous enough to
jettison the poor creature 30,000 feet
above the Sea of Japan it was a bad day
for everyone involved so the next time
you complain about a little snow or rain
just remember that some poor suckers in
Japan had a cow dropped on them and be
thankful if you enjoyed this video
please like and subscribe to keep up
with the latest content and be sure to
check out my channel for my other videos
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video